[موسيقى]
أعزائي المتسوقين مرحبًا بكم في
بايك في موسم عيد الميلاد هذا، ندعوكم
إلى التوقف عن التسوق بينما
تسقط القنابل، قُتل أكثر من 20 ألف شخص في غزة
هذا الموسم الشتوي بتمويل من
أموال الضرائب الخاصة بكم عندما تشتري علامات تجارية
مثل لوريال شانيل وتصنع  من المؤكد أن إسرائيل
يمكنها مواصلة الإبادة الجماعية
للفلسطينيين بينما كنت
تبحث عن الهدية المثالية، لقد
قتلت إسرائيل ستة أطفال كل
ساعة ستة أطفال كل
ساعة خلال الشهرين والنصف الأخيرين،
قُتل 8000 طفل،
أظهر تضامنك مع
الشعب الفلسطيني المضطهد.  ثقف
نفسك حول الإبادة الجماعية، تحدث إلى
أصدقائك عن
الاحتلال، تم إلغاء عيد الميلاد، أسقط
أكياس التسوق الخاصة بك وقاطع
العلامات التجارية التي تدعم الإبادة الجماعية الإسرائيلية ضد
الفلسطينيين، البحر، فلسطين سوف
تتحرر